Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier, (hOi Mark!) and welcome back to POPGOES. Now
We're on the fifth night, and it shouldn't be, too bad. Now it's gonna be bad,
And I'm gonna die a lot, and everything's gonna be horrible, and you can shut the f up.
Oh God, Weasel is going, I didn't even think about it. Ah, I forgot that we're going right away, I don't know where the party room is.
Shut up, shut up
I got stuff to do, and I've got things to worry about, and it's not you. That might be the party room, or no,
That's the birthday room. Where are you going, buddy-boo?
There's something else here that I need to worry about besides just these people because I only died...
Only died cuz they stole my phone cuz they didn't give an another heat in their lives
And they need a little more in the vents if I'm gonna be able to do that. Why are you not going anywhere?
Why are you not going any- Why is no one going anywhere? Why is no one go- okay. There we go. Where'd you go to?
Where the hell? Oh.
Ah, that's the party room! Okay, that makes more sense. Okay. Alright, I got it, not too bad -
Not too bad, not too bad. I know he's going back in that same room that he just went in
Hey, stop that. [Loud screech]
*worried*   Hi!
Sorry sorry, sorry sorry, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Sorry. I caught you peeping I didn't mean to cut your peeping like that
Ergh.
Birthday room? How quaint. How droll. I know where you go. Are you ladies? Oh hello?
I didn't mean to ask if you were ladies, I meant if you were still there
Yellow, doo.
Okay, got that easy-peasy. Oh shit. I lost him. I sure did I get it
I don't know if I got that oh, I think I got it. Okay. Wow, wow I'm great well
I'm amazing this came Wow I'm really cool Wow really awesome
you know yeah pretty cool what I managed to do with a little bit of panic and a lot of elbow grease a
lot of spit flying at my screen
lot of unnecessary I've
Fucked it I
Fyucked it real hard there. Oh, I was bragging about how great I was and I got caught in the ass
Not like that. Like that no no that's that's not what I meant I didn't I didn't get caught him yeah
I I bragged and bragging is, Hi, bragging is bad.
Don't brag.
brag oh
Oh, I don't know what that is! that's new
What do I do about that?
oOooo Shiiaegh
Dead aren't I Oh?
Something
Changed I don't like that. I don't like that. I know he went in there
You don't need to tell me you went in there who the frick
was that
and Why I do what you don't you don't need that phone. Why I shut down that room
Aisha Oh come on I shut down the room well, that's hardly fair
This seems a little bit precocious. I don't know if precocious is the right word to use about it, but
Hello, oh hello. Hey, it's a whole party here. Why did the ladies? Go? Where did the ladies go shit? Oh?
Frick a dick. Oh, you're there okay that seems far. Are you sure you want to travel that far?
For the birthday room for the big birthday boy with this bonkin big birthday presents get bonked bingo Bongo
okay, give me I
don't know if
It's gonna happen with them
Little little little the tiny itty bitty, you know the horrible horrible
(spook) Hi, sorry, the horrible horrifying skeleton that I saw of some
endoskeleton skelotypo
Oh, shit, where'd he go.
Frick oh my god, where is he oh?
No a fraction of a soucant (second) to loot (late) oh
and they're gone too - I'm fubbernobed.
Ok well I'm still fubbernobed but hey. He doesn't have all the parts
He's got some of the parts, but not all the parts which gives me some time not a lot of time but some time
Why that is weird why would you be doing something anything there would be not supposed to do that
No something went something went all kerfitzled
I'm hoping that it's not death :<
Little stressful, I can't imagine what a 20/20 mode of this I mean with time
I'm gonna eventually memorize the whole layout I'm gonna know exactly where he's going each and every time who wants to maneuver somewhere
but for now
For now at least I'm learning a few th-
God damn, but I did it again
I was talking up my own ass again
Talking about and around in near or on my own ass, and then I got caught
With my ass hanging out
I need to stop talking about my ass before this is over, people are gonna start assuming for this (?)
[spook] WaOh wAoh okay alright okay alright (x4)
Okay alright alright alright alright
let's have them to see how many times I could say alright and still not be funny so what I've realized is cuz I'm an
idiot obviously they start from 9 and obviously the only way they can go is 8 through the other ones so
Derp of course they're coming that way.
oh shit, did I miss em.
Oh, how how did you sneak snonk I get talking and then you fook me oh?
aW Gershderrnmert
Frick a Duke you
Goddamn it. You sack- Oh, hi yeah
Okay, alright fine whatever.
You still need one more piece, and I still need to punch you in the dick
So once we get our schedules lined up
We'll book you in for a nice dick punch about that whoa what the fuck he moved wait
Did he oh he didn't move I saw that guy I saw the blink blornk. I assume that was a motion
No, okay I saw you. I saw you.  I was ready for you.
It's 5 a.m.. You're not gonna stop me. You might stop me everyone might stop me that endo-skeleton might stop me
But not today! it's hard to see you in there, but I know you're there hey you don't do that don't do that
dont do that (x2) you're there... I know you're there.. Oi you're not there uh oh
[spooked sound], you're getting too close to me stranger danger in DD
oh come on give me the 6 a.m. already. How much longer Do I gotta go. I'm assuming you know
No! he blink blonked!
I
assumed
is summade (assumed)
Give me my goddamn time yet. Is he in there huh no not that shut it down
Frick was that the last piece. Oh shit. Oh shit come on timer timer
YAY! Death not for me today! Eugh, fuck, that was stressful
I dunno why that was so stressful,
I made it stressful for myself by shouting and panicking
What do you have in store for us now? Oh it's not Freddie. It's the opposite of Frodo
So where are you gonna? Go straight up? Maybe maybe straight to the ticket at the tip top of  the tomper?
Maybe maybe tip top your top hat on top of Fred boy
They're kind of like passing on the torch if you know what I mean
Nope, not up there. So there's got to be something else in this hellhole that I have n-
[spook + cunfuzzled mark]
Well, that's weird
That must mean that all bonster (bonnie) over here must be to the left right?
That's the only thing that can mean that I mean a lot of things could mean that and I could be stupid
But you know I'm gonna assume that I kind of halfway know what I'm talking about. Maybe this is gonna leave me the woo oh
That's a guitar. It's broken all the tragedy. Oh, it's getting dark over here. Huh oh?
Well, that's the sound that you can make this moment or you could not make it. That's also an option. Oh
It's the Bonnie paper plate that appeared randomly in five nights at Freddy's 2
Which is arguably the best Five Nights At Freddy's game
[random inhale]
And something about shadow bonnie!
Okay alright well someone has shed their bowtie and pants so ah
We seem to be going in a circle. Why oh?
Hi, you lost an ear and pants
Sixthe night you say oh, I see how it is
Well, what's gonna happen in this one? How much more shit? Can you throw at me? [alot]
I mean I can handle a lot of shit, but you know even an expert like myself has to have days off
Know straight through the night okay here we go. I guess yeah, whatever who needs breaks, breaks are for the weak
Answer the damn call or we ooo shit
[phone dude] Hey, uh, there are only a few minutes of recording.
I was thinking about some things, since my last message
[inhale]
[phone dude] I feel like i haven't been honest enough with you
I've been trying, please know that
But there are some things that i just..
[another exhale]
I have a question for you.
[SPOOK]
Personal question, i'll try to set an example
There's this uh, person, that's really close to you and he's recently been acting strange
Maybe a bit scary
People say he's done horrible things
But you, you've trusted him
For all your life, he's been listening to your problems and you really, look up to him
Even if this person has made big mistakes in his life, If he does regret it in the end,
Would you be willing to forgive him? If you know who he is, would you look past his errors and
Try to bring him back?
Into your life?
Do you think, You could trust him
[stippy steps/ knocking]
No, this will do
Thank you for working with me so much, this is the end of your shift at the Pop Goes Pizzaria. Go let me know your answer oh
[Markiplier] Sure why not yes
Okay, I'm gonna go with a big ol. Yes. Good thing. This job. Led to a survey. That's my favorite thing about this job
Shit, uh have they moved they maneuvered they already on their way
Don't know how can I know I don't think they're there yet?
Hey, yeah, yeah. Yeah, oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah, I
Africa the guy
What?
Person
How fast was that?
I was not paying attention
I'm about to get bit in the brain
I'm about to get bit in the brain ~
There comes
Ow, my brain, ow, okay. Alright.
So that is night five, and there's apparently one more "official" night.
And, uh
Yeah something was going on with that call. I just don't know what. Someone was tapping on something to get him to be done
but I just can't understand why I've almost out of time for recording that either means someone's taking you away from the place or
Something else is happening, so let me know what you think down the comments below and as always
In the next video (Buh bye!)